bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo su breaking
the band the bank insieme ragazzi perché
c'è stata stone and play che mi stati
forti hanno peraltro ragazzone un po
anche a della madonna difesa davvero da
due uomini del cazzo però vabbè devo
entrare in banca a posto perciò wrecking
ball c'è la palla demolizione così non
ti fai notare zio credimi che no non ti
vede nessuno sono convinto stesso
farcela poi fa o come presentimento che
sta per succedere una stronzata
ma come faceva a saperlo
la demenza nel cervello siamo un full
nei riti e meno amico mio mi spiegavo e
cazzola teneri con la pala c'è da alan
ascoltami se fai delle cagate è
ovviamente la banca ea destra e tu scavi
sotto un genio è chiusa in questo
ragazzino quale gli piaccio nei treni
esclusione però in questo che ah ok
perfetto e un muro ovviamente quel muro
laddove saltato fuori non lo sappiamo
io mi devo già incazzare perché sui
giallorossi
e normale che se sei un efficiente nel
cervello però sei più figo adesso lei ha
ormai li sto provando tutti i ragazzi
che non becco quello cioè solo per
entrare dobbiamo fare devo ancora
entrare permettevi conto che cos'è
adesso forse ci siamo lega forse ci
siamo
ma proprio un cazzo devi provare il
sacco anche se non c'è un cachet un
camion che sta facendo
dentro un sacco mi sembra l'idea miglio
ho capito no no ma certo ma certamente
perché essa i sacchi pieni di dollari
rimangono per strada ma mi sembra giusto
e adesso lo mettono nel camion cioè
questo voi ditemi se non devo incazzati
seabra bravissimo sempre sei un genio
siamo entrati ma ragazzi non ha
funzionato un cazzo però questo ha
funzionato non si sa perché ce l'ho già
nel deretano ragazzi fantastico non
vedevo che è diventato è finito cioè se
riesci secondi di gioco il giorno questo
è veramente il gioco più più corto che
abbia mai fatto nella mia vita questo è
il videogioco più corto che abbia mai
fatto nella mia vita è assoluto
d'accordo ragazzi sicura e tipo quello
prima è finito il 0,2 secondi o qualcosa
del genere ma il giorno dopo che sarebbe
infiltrata in via ship che sarebbe una
roba da enel seguito dicono che ho fatto
la scorsa volta di save the prison devo
entrare in aeroplano port ragazzino è un
tizio che fa il caffè non lo so
l'aggravamento facciamo un play perché
noi degenerando la partenza è qualcosa
di epico tra i partiti così essere duri
che ragazzi e si sa che può 700 tizio io
dio basetta mente mente ragazzi mi
stanno ingaggiando per puntare su
quell'aereo complimenti ragazzi sono già
mi sono già infiltrati in una banca
quindi vogliono hustle d'armi è una cosa
che cazzo siamo partiti ragazzi spero
che questo sia leggermente più lungo ma
credo di sì stavolta vado con sticky and
che l'ha più
[Applauso]
ecco perfetto cioè ha funzionato a
funzionare veramente cosa c'è in giro
point e noci e facciamo ball chen dai
facciamo questo non lo so cioè sarebbe
una sono leggermente morto tipo a nostro
cadendo con una cassaforte ma giusto
[Applauso]
ho vinto veramente una presa per il culo
mi sembra ecco mi sembrava strano retry
facciamo giro poi interno sosta trollata
è uscita bene pensavo pensavo
effettivamente che che avessi finito ma
è volta la cassaforte
infatti non serve un cazzo andiamo
indietro che migliora facciamo cannon
ball boy è ben a mente andando il ceo
questa roba vecchia troya è solo un
piccione che è entrato dal parabrezza
niente di che tranquille laser c'è il
cast facciamo io farei il trash che non
somigli vigato troppo negativo io c'ho
una bolla io sono troppo indistruttibile
ecco forse non facciamo al laser ma che
mi sembra anche questo figo roba tipo e
la madre è che se va bene è morto
chiunque praticamente ovviamente una
seria è la cosa migliore contribuire ok
con la sede con la sedia sono andate
effettivamente avanti ragazzi oggi c'è
uno con una sedia con una sedia in una
bolla che ti jack a caso ho cercato non
ci credo veramente ragazzi si è fatta
all seccato devo prendere quel tizio
perfetto ragazzi devo prendere tizio che
fa il caffè è quello
no non ho cliccato non so ancora mite
che facciamo veloci e fagioli fagioli e
ovviamente su poi sicuri da dietro la
fantasia era ovviamente quello veramente
siamo techno trousers sarebbero i
pantaloni metallici
io mi sono sempre chiesta due cazzotti
là fuori sta roba sto tizio da dove c'è
la tutele muta anche cosa che forse non
funziona mental band forse non glielo do
in testa tipo ok e tipo crollato un
aereo ma facciamo tifo roero che è
l'ultimo quindi credo di provare questo
ho fatto ma come chiesto questa sfida mi
cazzo ti indichi devo scegliere tra tra
cui mio figlio di lei ha fatto lo so che
lo yo yo ragazzi una specie di tributo
final fantasy
facciamo
rai trade and men ok io ci avevo una
motosega tutto lo ha ucciso con la
motosega cosa fare ho vinto ma oggi
ormai clicco a casa da gava che tanto
noi l'hai del getto io farei jazz bossa
anche anche se so che non sono questi
ovviamente rider glider al deltaplano il
deltaplano e figo si è fatta nessuno
fosse pd sicuro viene offerta va bene
così l'ho preso regalo ho preso il tizio
adesso devo uscire di qua dove eravamo
all'inizio poche parole film mm nel sud
non stai devi stare zitto tu devi darmi
il caffè zio ragazzi l'ho preso avremo
che abbia vita come cazzo ci arriviamo
all'elicottero paracadute deng thank
cioè adesso ve li mi spiegate come cazzo
facciamo arrivare con un carro armato
che sarebbe un cara mamma dove l'ha
tirato fuori in tenda dove la legge me
giustamente vivo ho vinto davvero vi
hanno sempre detto che mi pare che tutte
si può atterrare in sicurezza è una
puttanata pazzesca del di tecnica armati
che i carrarmati si atterra fatevi
chiamare a vedere cosa fanno gli altri
cos'è beef up cioè giusto per vedere che
cazzo di cose si erano inventati io ti
assicuro che se mangiavi la mia nonna
esplode vi ancora prime e se devo andare
cosa come 100 giochi un'oca provo a
bussare perché se mi apre qualcuno
salve giorno ecco questa è una
accoglienza di merda pensavo potesse
allora facciamo con l'acido che è meglio
quanto cazzo può essere stupido sto
gioco da 1 a 2 mila 827 fatemi capire
perché aveva 15 tre lune crei credo sia
l'unica decente
bene come no ovviamente la roba mia
arriva in testa è una sfida ho aspirato
tutto dopo sta spirando tutto l'aereo
dall'interno bellissimo
ok ce la fa a quest'ora buono ci siamo
ragazzi questo che una riunione
fantastico posso farti skies che serve
il caffè bello con gli occhi bellissimi
della colla e tra cui trans dimensiona
leiser io proverei questo trans
dimensionali ed è giusto perché non
voglio più dire questo nome che mi fa
paura quindi è diventato tutta una
dimensione fa quel senso di sta
stronzata fatemi capire una situazione
del genere la colla a che cazz osserva
io voglio giusto per vedere che cosa sta
facendo
pensavo facesse un art attack non sta
cosa qui prova ben più o meno la stessa
cosa ma perché james bond to della vita
non hai capito un cazzo dove giocherà
sto gioco prima di lui sono io che sono
andato là flatform il robot è il verbo è
charles chao che provvediamo charles che
tutto dovrebbe fare due chiacchiere che
io chiamo quello che l'elicottero si
sbaglia ma bastiolo boell che mi sembra
il più intelligente
dopo quello di prima charles 6 inutile
con lui che ho fatto lo dirà
e sarebbe the hill di sonico c'è uno che
chiare che schiaccia pulsanti a caldo
ragazzi dominare moment si fonde le ossa
in poche parole facciamo fondere le ossa
io voglio capire come fa ma come fa ma
che cosa c'è un superpotere che fonde le
ossa come rimasto spiazzato tizio ma il
ragazzo è troppo magra il ragno io posso
distrarlo marco corrano giusto ragazzi
se queste non l'ho capita spiegate ma
giura non l'ho capita
cioè è difficile capire suo gioco e per
carità però stanno entrando con
l'elicottero barra la bomba no perché
tutti è una una bomba banana tipo altai
aveva anche il timer si finge o forse
gabrovec bostjan però non qualche altra
kacar e allora ci abbiamo fatto
ragazzino dice il tizio va frutto di
preti come mezzo di stronzo ho vinto
movimento cioè non ho capito un cazzo
dall'inizio alla fine però è un gioco
figo questo sicuro una cosa sola giusto
per farvi capire no perché sa cosa va
trattata la vedete questa ok
questa è matematica non ci sta capendo
un cazzo
ok perché comunque più comprensibile di
questa merda mi ricordo io lascio
perdere perché erano talmente che
possono chiudere qui ragazzi servizio è
piaciuto una solito assalto momento mi
piace anche a bagnare i facebook e che
ora divido tra la trascrizione forse
dovresti discrete lì ci vediamo al
prossimo video bello ragazzi